[Musique]
en robe de soirée ont tenues plus
décontractées 16 modèles défilent pour
la première fois sous les projecteurs et
les applaudissements du public
ils sont tous en situation de handicap
et avec ce défilé ces modèles ont voulu
changer les regards portés sur route
on est tous beau jeu malgré notre
handicap au niveau de l'intérieur et
quand on défile
ah ben on montera aux aux personnes
qu'on est beau aussi
et cette bouteille au maire il recense
langue défini compter que les personnes
handicapées ne sont pas sont pas que
qu'un bout de ferraille c'est aussi une
âme une beauté justement voilà des tirs
du poignet comme que mon corps on a un
nouveau thé qu'on ait un coeur qu'on a
les modèles sont prêts à défiler
maquillée et habillée par des stylistes
ils présenteront les créations
originales en imposant leurs codes de la
mode et du défi tenue s'était créée par
les trois stylistes et les natifs et ils
vont défiler ils ont fait des créations
et les modèles ba c'est eux qui pour
défiler et je voulais mettre en avant
l'antique à passer pour montrer qu'eux
aussi sont capables
pour ce premier événement le public a
répondu présent et les modèles ont
décidé de revenir encore plus nombreux
sur le devant de la scène lors de la
prochaine édition
[Musique]